I know that you have been campaigning
since what happened to your daughters
for the police to get it and from that
clip there the commissioner reacting to
that report do they get it
uh he's dropped a real clanger here
um and hopefully he will know that
because every report is picking him up
on that this isn't a time for semantics
this isn't a time to kind of dig your
heels in but this is an example of the
arrogance of the police in general
um what was needed and what is needed
and what I hope he will do is go away
and rethink what he's just said and I
will have the utmost respect for him if
he comes back and says
in hindsight I think it's more important
that I take people with me and use the
language that they understand
because
um
as as the presenter said she defined the
definition
and he's right as well when he's saying
you know we've got really big issues
here so why squabble why why focus on on
on the I'm not going to use that
language he's the word organization I
think instead of institutional yeah when
you look the T side by side like you
said it literally is semantics but does
this feed into
the response today which you know I
listed her radio phone in on the way in
today and people were very quick to call
in and defend the police not just the
Met police but the police officers in
general and that feeds into the debate
that you know it isn't all police
officers it goes back to the bad apples
but this report isn't necessarily
talking about
toxic individuals it's talking about a
system an organization that allows this
to happen and doesn't check it doesn't
stop it allows it to spread it might be
the few but it affects the many
well you know these WhatsApp groups you
know the will use the right language the
police took selfies of my dead bodies of
my girls and shared them with 30 odd
other police officers who clearly
thought like them otherwise you wouldn't
send it
and now that that isn't something that
will happen overnight you know the first
infringement might be something small
you get away with that very much like
cousins
you know him exposing himself was a
gateway to every time he did it and got
away with it
poor Sarah everard paid the price
and so the issue is
that
it is institutional it is and no one has
ever heard me say
bash the police I have family members in
the Met police
and so I know that there are good police
and in fact my family members who were
came with me to the trial
um they thought they thought over should
we leave the force because
do we really want to work for an
institution that can do this and
thankfully they they've stayed and I
said to them no you mustn't go
it's the bad ones that need to go and
please people do not
do not hang on to the that you need to
defend the police because the good ones
we know they're out there and you've
experienced both sides yeah right you've
experienced the two faces of them their
very best and then frankly they're very
worse yes and do you know what I've I've
remained friends with um Simon Harding
and my family liaison the lead police
officer in the investigation we're
friends we you know we he's been to see
me we've been out for meals and and so I
know what good policing is and so does
everybody else
this is not the time to be defending the
police because I've never bashed them
and never would well it's about our job
as the public to keep ourselves safe
from the police it's the police's job to
keep us safe as the public ultimately
it's the met that has to change itself
they're the words of baroness Casey and
looking at the Met it is such a massive
organization and one of the
recommendations is that if it can't
change it literally needs to be ripped
apart and built again and whether that's
you know made smaller and made up
differently I mean it's not up to us to
find the answers as baroness Casey said
but but
um I was having a conversation with
somebody in the the um green room and
basically
um they were saying you know how would
that work
um and we know Casey said that you know
austerity is has hurt them but if it's
too big to manage
then one thing you could do is take the
counter terrorism Department out and put
it with MI5 and you know the rapes and
assaults on women you could move that
let us talk about a specialist women and
children's Protection Service there we
go being set up that's it and so it's
doable
um but as you said it's not up to us I
mean if this has become my day job I
know and it's it's it's like I'm not in
the I've never worked in the police my
my field was religion and uh drama I was
a Drama teacher an assistant principal
of a secondary school but now you find
yourself policing the police yeah now
I'm now I'm I'm doing Senior Management
of you know and they they need help for
Outsiders who have the experience to go
in and and and and teach them how to do
this properly do you think this is going
to be a watershed moment I mean people
have been talking today at the
MacPherson inquiry after the death of
Stephen Lawrence that found the
Metropolitan Police to be
institutionally racist that was over 20
years ago now and numerous inquiries and
reviews into similar incidents have
happened and we find ourselves where we
are today
the baroness itself cited that 50 of
women don't have any trust in the police
at the moment because of recent events
do you have trust and faith in the
police that they can change that they
will actually do this themselves it's
not going to be your job anymore and
Other Mothers and Fathers and Families
like you yeah
the truth of matter is any changes that
we're seeing now
has been
the tenacity of victims coming forward
and speaking within the police speaking
to baroness Casey about their
experiences yes
and feeling safe enough to do that
um I think
I'm an optimist I can't help it I I I'm
still rooting that because if if
Mark can't do it um
no one can you speak to him regularly
don't yeah and check in with him and
it's not because he's particularly
special sorry Mark you know you're just
a man like anybody else but this
people have spoken they're they're
saying now we we can't trust you and we
can't have that with women but a simple
thing I never ever imagined for a minute
that a woman coming into a police
station saying that she'd been assaulted
by a man would be interviewed on her own
with a male
um police officer
it's just one of the one of the small
things that has to change to make a big
difference isn't it yeah I mean I just
want to leave viewers with a picture of
your daughters smiling if we could just
bring that up on the screen because of
course today's about this report but
it's also the work you're doing on
behalf of your girls this is how you
want to remember them just short summary
of your girls and what they were like
and how you want people to remember them
you know where you see them there they
were so playful and full of joy and they
were there they were there because they
were following covid rules you were
allowed only to me it was Bieber's
birthday that so she decided to have a
picnic you could only have 10 people
there were 10 people and they followed
the rules and if they'd have broken the
rules
they would still be alive now well Lena
ah
well I'm going to leave this interview
with their smiling faces Mina thank you
so much for coming in to talk to us on a
day that's difficult for you but I'm
sure there are so many difficult days
for you and you're doing wonderful work
on behalf of your girls and hopefully
the Met police will pick up the man
thank you for having me do that hard
work thank you